the last major science work that came
from the Large Hadron Collider the
collider finished in 2012 did pretty
well a Higgs Higgs boson emerged and
there's rightfully given Nobel Prizes to
on glare and Higgs himself then since
2012 it has been shut down and basically
I think it's like building a new machine
again the all the detectors have been
revamped the LHC itself all the magnets
have been tested and connections between
the magnets tested they've put in new
systems to try and guarantee that when
the beam goes around its it doesn't
stray off and cause quenches they're
about ready to go the ready to rock and
roll it's run - yeah and this run should
go for a few years now so Run 1 which
was the run from 2010 to 2012 they
managed to get the beam energy up to 40
V per beam so atetv whether they collide
in the indeed detectors now that
managing to get up to six and a half TV
per beam so 13 TV collisions so that's a
what 40 or 50 percent increase in energy
with that comes all sorts of benefits
and also they've managed they're hoping
to increase what's known as a luminosity
the number of collisions per second that
will be detected has gone from something
like if I remember my numbers right from
before 600 million a second up to over a
billion a second now so you've got many
more collisions at much higher energies
that means you're you're potentially
probing a new region of the energy space
if that's available to create new
particles was the key thing that they'll
initially be trying to do is make sure
that they've understood the Higgs the
Higgs field itself which is the field
that's responsible for the masses of the
fundamental particles that we've
discovered the Higgs but it's like going
into a gold mine and finding a nugget of
gold you want then just leave it there
and take it home and say that's it
you're now going to try and explore all
the properties you know about
and so one of the big questions would be
is the Higgs that we see the only Higgs
are there are other Higgs particles that
might be that the might be there that
come from beyond the standard model of
particle physics or if there aren't then
can we test the Higgs that's there to
such a degree that we we think we know
what how it should decay with the
standard model so we can by looking at
more and more events of the higgs
decaying we can actually test you know
to much more precision whether or not
the standard models fitting the data run
one hmm
gave us the heat so presumably the
energy levels were right we hit the
sweet spot that we needed to be smashing
at the right powers and speeds to show
us the Higgs yeah now that they're
juicing it up and smashing things even
harder hmm are they not moving away from
that sweets no no I will include that
spot it's it's that they've just got
much more energy so a TV was enough
energy there to actually produce a Higgs
Higgs as decay rapidly to ten to the
minus twenty seconds or so they've gone
again and what you pick up is the debris
of the d case of perhaps you know one of
the most clear-cut signs that they found
was pair of photons shooting out and
four leptons coming out by looking at
the distribution of those and the number
of those they were able to say this has
come from a Higgs well having even more
energy just means it's easier to produce
these Higgs so that you'd expect you're
going to produce even more of them
because there's all of this extra energy
there that can produce the Higgs but
what it also has potentially is imagine
there's a Higgs that at a TV
we couldn't produce we didn't have
enough energy to produce that Higgs that
might be coming from say a
supersymmetric extension of the standard
model or some extension then with with a
bit of luck with 13 TV maybe we just
enter that regime where occasionally we
can produce those Higgs and we'll look
for the decay of those as well for me
it's really an incredible thing that
happened in my lifetime if there's one
then we have a real issue which I don't
think we've touched on and you don't
hear very much about it's called the
hierarchy problem there are different
math scales that we experience in
physics the Higgs has got the mass of
125 GeV
that's that's the mass that we couldn't
predict it but that's what it came out
to be honking 25 point something now
there's another natural mass scale in
physics which is associated with the
Planck scale now where is the Higgs
scale is 125 GeV the Planck scale is
about 10 to the 18 GeV we don't really
understand is why Nature has done this
it corresponds in actual fact to the
fact that the the electroweak force the
weak force is something like 10 to the
32 times stronger than the force of
gravity why is the force of gravity so
small compared to the Elector the weak
force or another way of saying is why is
the mass associated with the Higgs
particle so much smaller than the
natural Planck scale which is a the mass
you associate up at the at the
gravitational scale the why that is a
problem is that we expect these two to
couple we know the Higgs has mass it
couples through gravity everything
couples through gravity and it gets
influenced by the mass of the of this
heavier particle to such an extent that
actually you expect the mass of the
Higgs to rise and rise and rise and rise
and rise until it becomes comparable to
that heavy mass scale the fact we don't
see that the fact that there is only
this one Higgs we see that has this mass
is why is it like that
how come its mass hasn't gone up to this
ultra high scale a single Higgs by
itself can't explain it we don't have a
nice mechanism to do it so this is one
of the key reasons why people have gone
beyond the standard model they've
introduced ideas which will actually
mean that the the natural rise of this
mass is is stopped the most well-known
example of this is supersymmetry
so what happens with supersymmetry is
when all the fermions the electrons the
proton also et cetera all the quarks
start coupling in to and interacting
with the Higgs and being driven up
driving the Higgs up to higher and
higher scales through other interactions
with gravity then what you actually do
is you introduce a new set of particles
the supersymmetric partners of all of
these electrons and quarks and they're
come in in such a way that they actually
cancel off all of these contributions
they
exactly cancel them off so as long as
supersymmetry holds these contributions
get canceled off so all of this rising
and the effective mass of the Higgs gets
gets brought down again because every
rise due to say an electron gets
actually compensated by by this electron
it's supersymmetric partner and it
brings it back down and this is a way of
then stabilizing the mass of the higgs
but the problem is it may not be a
problem with a bit of luck the LHC will
find something we haven't seen any
evidence you have supersymmetry right
the what we found is all perfectly
consistent with the standard model so
one of the things we've or we've already
established by the fact that we haven't
seen any evidence of these
supersymmetric particles at the moment
that already puts a lower bound on the
mass that these particles can have we're
oh we've already reached energy scales
of atetv or so which means that the
supersymmetric particles must have
masses at least above that energy scale
remember e equals MC squared the idea
that we're doing here is that we're
colliding the protons the protons are
annihilating and the the energy that's
released is then sort of redistributed
into new particles if somehow all that
energy could get redistributed into a
pair of supersymmetric particles then we
know that that that pair would have to
have a mass of order at least of order 8
TeV or so otherwise we've already seen
them they would have already been enough
energy in the collision and that isn't
so we have to go to higher energies in
order to be able to hopefully probe the
regime where these heavier particles are
existing so as long as the heavier
particles aren't too heavy compared to
the 13 and 1/2 TV then we should be able
to produce them so what happens out here
headed by your data comes out it goes
down these cables here it goes all the
way out it goes downstairs and it goes
into this room that's full of
electronics the electronics brings it
all in and then it filters it it makes
very fast decisions and says I like that
I don't like that and it throws away the
vast majority of it it really makes you
feel like you really in the hall
this machine now I mean of course where
it stood now you wouldn't be able to
stand when this thing's on too much
radiation flying around too many
particles licked